I'm in the midst of launching something
I've been working on for years. Uh, and
I'm launching it pretty
unconventionally. I'm giving this deck
of cards away. It's a future focused
sequel to the We Connect cards intended
to spark conversations that uh, actually
edit the future rather than just
connecting people. How do we have
conversations that actually edit the
future? Uh, and I'm giving them away for
free to every single person that comes
to the Connector Summit. And I'm going
to be hosting a free training on best
practices and favorite activities, etc.
to use them, blah blah blah. You should
come to the Connector Summit. What I'm
here to share with you today is what I
think is a really compelling idea which
is one questions are the uh can be the
right question at the right time to the
right person can be an edit button to
what happens next. I mean every question
literally changes the words that come
out of somebody's mouth. But also some
questions actually get you thinking and
envisioning and seeing what's possible.
Like for example, if I were to ask you
what possibilities do you see for
yourself in the future? You would take
what's in your imagination and you would
speak it out in response to somebody.
And as soon as you do, your imagination
becomes a little part of reality, a
little piece of reality, and you move
one step closer toward that possibility.
Now, what I want to share with you is
what's on the back, because I think it's
a really compelling uh idea or story
behind it. My uh late co-founder and
co-author, Will We Wise, uh we co-wrote
Ask Powerful Questions together. He he
died with a box of fortune cookies on
his desk and he kept that box box of
fortune cookies there because on uh
virtual workshops uh over co he would
hold up the box of cookies as a reminder
for people to create their future rather
than leaving it up to a cookie. And so
when I went to design what's on the back
of uh the future focused we connect
cards, what I set out to do was uh to
put something on the back that made the
future feel as easy as cracking open a
fortune cookie.
I think for most people in most parts of
the world right now, the future feels
like a little uncertain, a little shaky.
You're like always looking around the
corner like what's going to happen next?
And so on the back I wanted to put so I
took what what I believe to be 60
ingredients that make the future a
little bit easier. So imagine these
cards spread out on a table and I just
simply invited people as they walked
into the room to choose an ingredient
that makes that might make the next week
a little less painful or choose an
ingredient that might make the project
we're working on that much better. And
so I had uh Tori, a much more talented
artist than I am, take these 60
ingredients and visually illustrate them
in some way.
You want people to take risks, get them
into a conversation about what's one of
the biggest risks that you've taken or
that has actually paid off, right?
You want to talk about priorities and
prioritization and you want people to be
become aware of what they're actually
prioritizing.
ask them, "What are you currently
prioritizing the most?" And all of a
sudden, that will become clear and
salient. And then once the answer's out,
we get to decide, "Oh, I'm actually
prioritizing doom scrolling at night
through Tik Tok or YouTube or Facebook,
whatever your drug of choice is,
instead of prioritizing reading." And
I've told myself, I really want to be
reading more. Okay, that's it. If you
want the cards, uh, they're not
available to the public. They are only
available to people who show up to the
connector summit, but they are available
for free to everyone that shows up to
the connector summit. There's probably a
link around to sign up for that.
What crap? This is already like an
unedited raw video, but what crap
marketing if like I pitched all this and
then there's not a link to the summit
somewhere. All right, have an awesome
day.